this is a Wendover productions video in
collaboration with real-life lore and
made possible by loot crate is the
European Union a country it's a bit of a
strange question with an easy answer but
a difficult explanation the answer is no
the European Union is not a country but
you can move between countries without
passing through border control work
between countries without a visa and
they use the same currency and there are
elections to a single Parliament and
there's a single government and there
are official languages in a single
economic market and a single aviation
mark game this is beginning a sound off
alike country let's do a 90 second recap
of how the EU works this is the European
Union there are 28 member states
including the UK which has voted to
leave the EU but just hasn't yet gone
through the process to leave of those
these are in the Schengen zone meaning
that there are no border controls
between them that means that a typical
border crossing in the EU looks like
this these four are legally obliged to
be in the Schengen zone but just aren't
and these two have opt outs in their
treaties that exempt them from being in
the Schengen zone these countries are
part of the euro zone meaning the euro
is their sole legal currency these guys
are obliged to join the euro zone once
they reach a certain economic target
which they haven't and these two have
opted out exempting them from the euro
zone each member country of the European
Union elects its own members of the
European Parliament known as MEP s but
the Parliament can't make laws by itself
laws are proposed by the European
Commission who work kind of like an
executive branch they then go to the
Parliament who if they approve it send
it to the Council of the European Union
while the Parliament represents the
people of a European Union since the MEP
s are elected by direct election the
council represents the governments since
it's made up of a rotating roster of
national ministers if a proposed piece
of legislation makes it through both the
Parliament and the Council of Europe it
becomes law so that's how the European
Union works at least a massively
simplified version but how do countries
work or rather what makes a country a
country well calling a country a country
is a bit misleading because the word
country can mean a lot of things but
you're probably thinking of when I say
country is sovereign states France Japan
the US etc but there are non sovereign
states that are countries
Scotland is a country indisputably but
it's not a sovereign state it's part of
the sovereign state of the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland so once again what makes a
country a country well there's something
called the declaratory theory of
statehood that sets out four criteria
for statehood the first is a permanent
population a country is not a country
without people so it needs people in its
territory permanently the EU easily has
this more than half a billion people
live within its borders if it were a
country it would be the third most
populous on earth and have one of the
highest GDP s in the world the second
requirement is a defined territory it's
a common misconception that a new
country can only form an unclaimed
territory according to the declaratory
theory a sovereign state can be created
in an area where another sovereign state
already exists just look at North and
South Korea both claim the territory of
each other and yet they're both
sovereign States the European Union has
a territory but it's a bit fuzzy any
territory that you can call you
territory is also territory of other
entities the countries that make up the
EU but that doesn't necessarily stop the
EU from having a territory going back to
the example of the UK the official
sovereign state the United Kingdom of
Great Britain and Northern Ireland
really doesn't have any of its own
territory
any territory of the UK is part of
England Wales Scotland or Northern
Ireland each country's by themselves the
u.s. is in a similar situation States
act kind of like many countries and
there's really no federal territory that
is not part of a state's territory
especially given its open border policy
the EU territory is in function
indistinguishable from that of any
sovereign state the third requirement is
a government and the government can't be
just a puppet of another sovereign state
the government needs to have what's
called an essential core of Independence
as I've mentioned the EU has a
government but for a few reasons the EU
government is different from that of a
sovereign state here's the problem the
--use government is not independent the
power comes from below as in the power
comes from the Member States the power
of sovereign states also comes from
below but in that case it's the people
that give a state power in the case of
the EU
since power is granted by sovereign
states those states are really above the
EU in power and therefore the EU
government is a subservient government
that violates the criteria for a truly
independent government although what's
the difference between this and the UK
government then the country of countries
the United Kingdom is also made up of
countries so isn't their government
subservient well in the EU there's a
system and structure to leaving whereas
in the United Kingdom or really any
other country the entities within the
sovereign states cannot leave without a
change in government structure and
procedure when parts of sovereign states
leave sovereign states they do so
typically without a legal right but
rather a moral right it's called the
right to revolution according to the
philosopher john locke when a government
no longer serves the people as in it
fails to protect the right to the people
or becomes the entity that people need
protection from there is a near
universal moral understanding that the
people can either overthrow or leave
that government members of the EU can
choose whether or not to continue
membership on a legal basis rather than
a moral one the whole structure and
system was set up by the Member States
so even though it is overseeing the
states the power originates from the
states they oversee the continued
existence of the EU relies on the will
of its members to continue the system
that is never the case with an
independent government that being said
while the origin of power may be
different the EU government functions in
most ways like any other government it
is different branches agencies economic
systems leaders and more so while it's
different the EU does partially fulfil
the government requirement for statehood
the last criteria for statehood outlined
in the declaratory theory is the
capacity to enter into relations with
other states and the EU absolutely has
this there are ambassadors to the EU
ambassadors of the EU embassies of the
EU embassies to the EU intergovernmental
organisations between the EU and non-eu
countries treaties between the EU and
non-eu countries and more while most
foreign relations are handled by
individual member countries there are
absolutely foreign relations of the EU
as a whole so the European Union has
fulfilled each criteria for sovereign
statehood on our list but it still isn't
a state here's the problem
statehood as in being a sovereign
country is not a natural phenomenon no
part of nature creates countries you can
call salt salt if it's made of sodium
chloride that's the requirement for salt
being salt and we can't change that
that's how nature makes salt we created
the idea of countries there are social
construct so society decides what is a
sovereign country and what is not well
we can lay down a number of requisites
for statehood there are just guidelines
to achieve the final goal society's
acceptance of a country we can't just
say these criteria make a country a
country unless individuals believe in
those criteria since countries like all
social constructs only work if there's a
collective belief and following of that
system it's similar to money money only
works if everyone believes that pieces
of paper equal value countries only work
if everyone believes that certain
imaginary lines separate who and what
leads people in the case of statehood
you can't just ask every person in a
society whether or not they think a
country is a sovereign country there are
socially accepted countries already and
therefore those act as a proxy for
society to decide whether a country is
sovereign or not a country's sovereignty
is judged off of how many other
sovereign countries recognize its
sovereignty the European Union is not a
sovereign state because nobody accepts
it as one while it may function in many
ways like a sovereign country it is not
one because sovereignty is neither its
goal or desire this shows you just how
difficult it is to define what a country
is super national organisations like the
EU act like countries but at the same
time so do some sub-national entities as
in parts of countries most specifically
in the u.s. states have a level of
sovereignty that blur the line between
what is part of a sovereign country and
a country itself what is the difference
between a state in the United States and
a country they fulfill almost all of the
criteria that you just heard about so
that's why I asked the question in
collaboration with Wendover productions
the United States a country over on my
channel real-life lore please do be sure
to check that out it's a great video
from a great channel a lot of you asked
how you can support the channel and I
have a great fun way
courtesy of loot crate loot crate is a
monthly mystery crate that brings
collectibles apparel tech gadgets art
and other gear right to your door they
have a bunch of different themes to see
what you like and if you sign up using
the link try loot crate comm slash
Wendover you'll support the channel so I
can keep doing better and better videos
on top of that if you use that link you
can take 10% off by using the coupon
code bridge 10 these boxes are a
fantastic deal each has more than $45
worth of gear for as low as 11
ninety-five a month plus shipping that's
the cost of about 4 cups of coffee it's
a great gift for Christmas or a great
way to reward yourself once again if you
sign up using the link try loot crate
comm slash Wendover and the code bridge
10 you'll get 10% off and help support
Wendover productions other than that you
can also help this channel by
contributing on patreon where a hundred
percent of the funds go right back into
the channel
I even release expense reports at the
end of each month you can also get great
rewards over there like early access to
videos stickers handwritten letters and
most recently t-shirts you can also
order a t-shirt by itself for only $20
through dftba the link is here and also
in the description other than that
please make sure to follow me on twitter
at 1-over pro watch my last video on
every country in the world here check
out my fan moderated subreddit here and
most of all subscribe to this channel to
receive all my future videos right when
they come out lastly this is the final
Wendover productions video of 2016 and i
want to sincerely thank every one of you
for your amazing support I started this
year with about 3000 subscribers and now
I'm almost at 300,000 it's been an
awesome year all thanks to you guys
happy holidays and I'll see you in 2017
for the best year of videos you've ever
seen